[Music]
it's time for everyone's favorite MIB
[ __ ] segment right so this one I like
these it's titled MIB [ __ ] for not
pulling the car over for my wife this is
what they wrote I thought he was gonna
say map pulling out for my wife okay
sometimes we were driving back from the
grocery store which is about 25 to 30
minutes away from our house we live far
from town on the way back my wife really
had to pee and was wanting to go on the
side of the road cars kept and she would
have been seen and ticketed I told her
to just wait ten more minutes and we'll
be home I'll get there as quick as I can
she said she wasn't sure if she could
make it when we got home I thought she
would rush inside she ended up just
getting out of the car and squatting on
the driveway principal yeah I ended up
apologizing after I saw how much she
peed the poor girl pee for like a minute
or two straight and I guess she started
to wet herself when she stood up which
is why she went in the tribe driveway
she still mad at me saying her bladder
aches and I apologize for making her
wait but she said I was she said I was
concerned about it being illegal she
thinks I'm an [ __ ] am i I think
that's two folds they're like why
couldn't you pull over and find a place
like I've pulled over at a store or a
gas station why did she wait so he said
all right he wrote edit I would have
stopped somewhere but everything is
closed because of quarantine why are
there so many cops at this town that
they could just gonna get caught amount
of what yeah and why did she just pee on
the seat refuse to pull over I'll be
like I'm gonna pee in the car I'll
threaten them and I'll [ __ ] stick my
dick out well but she's nice vagina
[ __ ] [ __ ] I get why she wouldn't cuz
that's probably her car too yeah I might
be able to set off my own pee if I was
driving with
she wants you so bad I've got to do it
she gets to get out you be like [ __ ] you
that's her fault yeah so a lot of people
were responding okay first of all what
do you guys think [ __ ] he's just
pulled over I think he was trying to be
like nice for her it just I just think
he was concerned for her yeah he wasn't
trying to be an [ __ ] but it just came
out to her that she was those sirens are
coming after her for someone peeing on
the street right now okay so the
internet concluded that he is an [ __ ]
I knew it yeah just go over because they
were saying so like the top the top
comment thing says you're the [ __ ]
unlike men who can whip it out and pee
relatively discreetly on the side of the
road I can tell you that squatting down
to pee in public is a last resort for
most women your wife wouldn't have been
asking if it weren't an absolute
emergency I don't know about that yeah
I'd be pissed too if my husband thought
he knew better than me and about my own
bodily functions so a lot of people just
run the wrong way face off in the fact
that he just was like no no no I know
better than you like but that could go
both ways no cuz there are women out
there which we know that will just
that's not the last resort but the first
resort I need to pee Wow and don't just
[ __ ] squat and pee probably
especially drunk I get that I get the
whole driveway thing though because when
you get home and you just think of the
bathroom its Amelie coming up when you
have to take a [ __ ] in your water that's
what I was thinking like Julie coming up
I see the house already it's all it's
game over
okay she won in the minute even if she
wanted to she was intimated she would
have dripped like a [ __ ] snail all
the way to the [ __ ] what if she dove
for it don't worry forever no for the
bathroom is it coming out watch in the
window they're coming I was diving I've
been in situations not like within the
last I was a year that I had to go so
bad I'm taking off my underwear and
there's been streaks Oh sticks on the
floor mysamma yeah under way because I
had to go so bad wow how do you die for
a toilet oh yeah it's like going to toys
like hockey get the docket yet they're
like no
if you go forward like you just run out
your pants are down everything and you
go bold like this way just hug it [ __ ]
like that mom take a [ __ ] like that you
bring your laptop in there you it's
working
take it like a cool kid in class you
know you know mr. Miyagi the the the
real mr. Miyagi I there's a character a
Karate Kid
he's based off of a real cry oh yeah so
and he has a karate dojo here and
something demurrers yen
Foom your demo room will tomorrow so
when he first came to the states he
would take a [ __ ] like this and write
poetry or whatever because he didn't
he's never seen a Western toilet before
so he would use the toilet like this and
he's like oh how convenient
yeah was that before they're Japanese
toilets got all Thai technic yeah yeah
it's like they have better toys than we
do now Japanese toilets were just on the
floor like like Asian like all the agent
Doyle is done you just push the button
when you're done off to reach back like
would you like everyone's using the
toilet wrong I know I'm gon use it like
that I gotta try it
i'ma try my neck no you guys convinced
me I'm like good for that not Western
ones it's all pointing in the front
there's no like surfer guys look like a
boy or maybe it's the safety reason yes
like this someone comes into the clothes
you had to take off your pants actually
yeah yeah no dude like I okay there have
been emergencies where I have to pee so
[ __ ] bad that I'm like okay pull over
I need a pee right now and I'm literally
there on the side of the road and I
can't pee what why cuz you're nervous
don't know I don't know like even even
there have been times like when I was
younger too like I'd be swimming in the
ocean and I'm like oh [ __ ] I gotta pee
so bad so bad and then I'll be around
people and they're like just pee like
we're in the ocean just put compete and
I'm like I can't know what it is I think
it's just you're so psychologically used
to being in a bathroom that's hard cuz
I've been in the same blackness the
swimming pool I watch I was alone and
I'm still just it's so hard for me to
actually force it to come out
Wow make sense cuz I thought it was like
the water pressure something say all my
bladders no it's like the ones out it's
like so when you walk would you like in
the ocean you feel a warm patch eunuch
somebody peed or in a blue light this is
nasty we're like okay it's one good I
pee on myself and throw my pants away
and just walk around naked if I lived it
was socially acceptable what's why would
you wear pants at that point yeah I
don't want to be homeless you can it's
socially acceptable for homeless people
to do that right by like if we were just
chilling right now and then I just let
one go and I'm like it's wet and I
[ __ ] take off my pants and throw it
over there and just continue hanging out
like an animal yeah yeah that would be
so comfortable you could wear adult
diapers you know no but you have to have
the pee on you like that's what I don't
don't dive really you are oh no I should
try it though I have some more why did
you want view it cuz I wanted to I
wanted to buy the same clothes as ty cus
we could take matching pictures and I
have a hard time finding matching
clothes and I'm like what if I just buy
a diaper and he has a diaper and then we
could take push together but I bought
adult diapers I know you that video clip
popped up in my explore page on
Instagram and I was like he actually did
yeah it wasn't the first time he wore
diapers it'll fall apart yeah
our first viral video and Jacob got it
okay just like when it came in the mail
Jill saw you pull it I'm so excited my
baby you're not gonna believe what just
came in she said what is it I'm like
adult diapers and she goes do you ever
want to have sex ever again I'm like
that's incredible and then it made me
think what I could feel like he's gonna
grow up and be like yeah my dad was in
diapers with me
but do you guys you guys have a problem
like needing to poop when you travel or
when you go out the side of the house in
general I get actually I feel like I
don't even feel like I need to you know
I'm unstoppable dude I'm pooping
everywhere really if I travel I just
don't feel like I need to feel like four
times I hate public bathrooms I I have a
problem holding it in it's nice but when
you go camping but I can't I'll [ __ ]
everywhere I got no [ __ ] shame the worst
is the plane because I take long shits
like my ships are half an hour people
like if silly Bart would birth each time
slowly yeah this takes time to open up
the gates well it's like like they'll be
immediately dropped right yeah there's
still more than I weigh like hell yeah
you need more you need fiber dude you're
not eating enough fiber Ollie fiber
vegetable fiber really what kind of
every time this fiber fiber general have
you used a vortex button on the bidet at
the JK awfully awesome and don't force
it out that forces that shoots water in
like enema and then expands it and it
just all comes out how I bought that
exact same bidet bidet if you if you do
that and then say your girlfriend I
think if she wants to stick it from your
butt would you say no to that but yes of
the vortex no the vortex is a much
smaller stream it's like a super soaker
stream versus a finger fingers hurt it
doesn't make your butt cuz I I've used
the double day at the office and
sometimes it feels like it's stabbing me
in the butt oh yeah because yeah
it's like a laser printer you know by
face the sight the pressure we over day
I'm home too and I always put it to the
lowest level you know somewhat our
birthday at the highest [ __ ] left in
there first
I got votes dead there almost dead so
you have to use the control on the side
that's just one pressure oh I'm not
gonna lie the the bidets made me a
little curious about butt sex your own
butt that's interesting well yeah extra
long and you're like well I'm like why
not shoes that's what I've been saying
oh I'm like dancing out on rim jobs dude
maybe Devery god yeah you should try it
dawg you just listen and close later
investment for me might come the going
you're know what was our not inside okay
imagine this is the butt hole tongue
your where [ __ ] comes out that's not my
I'm not doing that okay what all I'm
saying
you rim job would not be interested dude
you sure you don't ask Casey you just
[ __ ] start licking that mother
whatever use the vortex button first
with my thighs huh let me use the vortex
button on the bidet before you came to
you know I don't
you've been vortex listen I'm okay with
P because you know yeah fine not [ __ ]
well all I'm saying is you should try
everything before calling it back listen
I am a huge advocate of that like I'll
try I'll do anything once but that's I
have my my hard-nosed bird you know men
have a g-spot in their booty hole and
I'm gonna experience this in maybe 10 or
15 years but my [ __ ] is to paint like
it hurts right now but I heard that the
most intense orgasms come from being
inside but do you need another guy to
help you find it
help me find mine
okay we didn't elaborate this whole
thing that you're curious about
oh no he's like the waves of the jet
stream shoots into your blood like what
is the thing you want me to do a rim job
oh it's awesome yeah no because you said
but SEC so I'm like well I know I don't
want any stretching my butt nothing I
thought you meant oh okay
yeah I thought you meant I want if to
put a [ __ ] strap on it well I wasn't
even thinking about what it actually was
I was just thinking that feeling is kind
of pleasurable I mean like replicates
that and then we said rim job I was like
oh that's that feeling you know what try
this all right
this whole dude all ladies out there you
would [ __ ] make your dude instantly
come while he's giving you missionary
right reach around and push his [ __ ]
just a little bit like a button Hey
that's the nuclear [ __ ] weapon right
there good we do that
it's Vinit vicinity that's the taste of
the bubble it's like it's like a teaser
no dude then this is the [ __ ] nuclear
war war three bun that's where all the
[ __ ] [ __ ] drain why do I want to do
that then I just you end the sex no no
explosion point build-up to it
Larry book the sex is over yeah you've
done that oh dude
I've had that done to me and I was like
what the [ __ ] just happened
[Laughter]
no there's a level or there's a danger
zone here okay I'm gonna use my
what's the difference between the taint
pushing and the butthole pushing
completely differently no getting a
finger in your [ __ ] and your one in
your [ __ ] it's different looks like
two different parts right so okay a
taint is like oh that's comfortable or a
finger can intrude because once it gets
past a certain point it's like it hurts
right all the matter shutting yeah like
I don't want it inside but then like I
can't clean my [ __ ] like the way Bart
does he goes inside and feel yeah like
like a submarine like periscope now how
did tissue paper break yeah I'm gonna
shower oh no no it's just that it's just
a pressure like it's just like snug like
a it's like an ass hug right so that
that pressure that just beep like that
oh my god dude the Niagara Falls just
[ __ ] defrosted inject it into the
pool dude do that when you're jacking
off to myself I tried it but it's not
the same oh do you ever use the bidet in
jackoff I've never done that but I'm
right now I'm just giving me ideas you
know couple days not pleasurable from
your day and then Jack like that's not
it's not pleasurable for me it hurts
I'll show you an out to be had a weird
angle true cuz the bidet you have to
kind of like you open up true yeah it
hurts the days kind of yeah it's not
that time you know got another hand so
cuz you need to you have a jackoff
material in one hand I don't know dick
in the other hand a knee also gotta push
the button to time that's true so you
looking at your hold you're doing like
this and you had to change the setting
yes the idea what saying that he needs
to be there with you and I'm whole terms
like porn yeah yeah yeah can you watch
Jack off without horn I feel like for
those memories better no Mary's like
material could you're very imaginative
it depends
it's I'm such a romantic or sometimes I
watch porn and I'm like this isn't real
[Music]